at least they're not named after a
dictator like me
no way
if you look up famous Josephs well he's
gone gaunt name
originally did you mean Grant yeah it's
gonna say did you mean the first thing
that comes up is why Gand
oh my god get your real name explained
okay that's a nickname okay all right
well let's let's why does the name God
what does the name gaunt mean let's have
a look
um
it's like well it's uh no one knows
oh it's a Thai name and it's it's not
pronouncing it you just submitted organ
67 Thai 30 Filipino no way
alternative meaning
God is an acronym for Grand for the life
that you'll live a for accepting your
forgiving nature ah for ROMs you know
how to have fun oh and for nurturing the
care you provide to all tea for treat
the you always have you're a real treat
well I I just thought God just sounds it
sounds so incredibly white I just
thought it was a white name I think you
know okay would it still classic white
people okay okay have we started yeah we
started this one okay recording
recording okay hello welcome to trash
station you are got some pre-talk there
I guess uh I'm is gone he's gone a white
name it sounds white like you gotta Miss
okay
his name Grant a Hugh Grant that sounds
white as [__] but that's Grant
it's like one letter different you know
and and the the fact that it's
pronounced like Grant you know gaunt is
uh it's a different like pronunciation
would it still sound white if I remove
the tea
gone yeah let's sound like a final
fantasy camera
so yeah yeah so interesting fact so my
name isn't actually like gaunts oh my
God so though it's actually Grand we
figured it out yeah yeah so the the Thai
pronunciation of my name is gone
so so the the reason the reason there's
a t at the end is because
um when translating like the Thai
alphabet to English alphabets the T in
God is technically a silent T so my
parents included that my parents did I
direct translations instead of uh
phonetic translation for my name when
translating my like when spelling it out
in English so the tea is meant to be
silent but of course how you can't
really explain that
um so your name would have been really
different if you were called gone
that would have changed everything
different podcasts
but not that I said it's just it just
something sounds wrong you know there's
the the T just like the T closes it you
know you need a hard tea at the end of
that yeah
but yes hello welcome to this episode of
trash taste I'm your host for today
gaunt gone with me are the two widest
named boys except Joey of course isn't
white I'm sorry Joey
he's got a white name though yeah yeah
Joseph white name
that would have been podcast if my name
was Joseph
John Connor and Joseph
[Music]
yes uh can I start with the rant oh god
with a with a good old-fashioned Branch
a good old-fashioned tangented brand
that has nothing to do with what we were
talking about but this has been on my
mind for like the past week okay wow
you've been really stewing the soil yeah
I have because uh I think I've had
enough
I [__] despise Cards Against
Humanities and I don't know if I've
talked about this before maybe I have
mentioned this but I've I think I've
reached a breaking point where I can't
take this anymore wait no no one plays
that anymore what you'd be surprised
because what triggered this did you play
it recently yes yeah okay okay for for
the record I've always hated Cards
Against Humanities I I think the only
time I've ever had fun with it was like
maybe Humanity I think it's Humanity
okay there's only one there's only one
Humanity
not enough Humanity it's not a different
planet yeah is it caused Against
Humanity yeah it's just Humanity I don't
know I made videos on it okay okay
um I think the only time I've ever had
fun with it was like the very first time
I played it and then every time
afterwards it's I've grown to like hate
it more and more
um I it went from like just a disdain to
like every [__] okay number one for
some reason reason why is it the only
times I ever played I get to play Cards
Against Humanity is like Anime
conventions Cards Against Humanity for
the longest time for me was like the
anime convention game well because I
feel like wanna be like kind of edge
Lords
[Laughter]
it makes sense it's for people who want
to be funny but can't think of their own
punch lines Yeah well yeah but then
there's also like the online of the
blank cards right yeah it was always
just about being edgy yeah and like who
could make the edgiest joke do you want
to win with a blank card just put in any
like horrible slur and you'll most
likely win it's like that's common see
that's that's not what I don't even like
about it because okay it's this is this
is every like this is every interaction
I've had with cars Against Humanity I'm
at a party or something I go or
gathering with some cool friends that I
very much Vibe with we are on a Vibe
we're talking [__] we're making jokes
yeah I'm having a good time and then
someone [__] pulls out cars against
Humanities uh I keep saying Humanities
someone
pulls out cards against Humanity because
because apparently we just weren't
having enough fun just vibing together
and making jokes naturally and they're
like I'm impressed I managed to get
everyone to be like yeah let's do it I
but here's the thing right here's the
thing everyone I I seem like I I've
always thought I'm the [__] crazy one
here I I think I I always think it's
like God's joke
I was crazy I didn't want to play the
card games I always thought I was the
crazy one because everyone would be like
okay yeah I'm down for cars Against
Humanity and I'm I thought I was the
only one that was like I am tall it was
a Humanity why I said no I I am not
against cars Against Humanity and the
thing is I can't Against Humanity yeah
I'm just Against Humanity this is this
is my this is my villain origin story if
someone pulls out another game of Cards
Against Humanity one vibing I am
literally gonna go on like a full-on
joker rant and just start my villain Arc
right because I I it's just like they
pull it out and I've never encountered a
situation where everyone goes where
someone just goes no I'm not not in the
moods right because I've said before I'm
not in the mood and I'm the only
[__] who says that and you know
I I say that but everyone else starts
playing so I'm like well I don't want to
be I have to play because I don't want
to be left out in the corner by myself
being uh being alone or whatever so for
the next like hour or two hours I have
to sit there and pretend that I'm having
fun as much fun as everyone else because
I have to pretend that uh all of these
jokes that be are being laid out in
front of me are as funny as everyone
else is apparently finding it because
people are laughing uh and I'm like am I
[__] crazy is this just not funny I
think the problem with Cards Against
Humanity is that like the especially a
lot of the jokes written on it and like
the punch lines and stuff like that that
haven't aged tremendously well yeah
they're very much like you know 2010s
humor which is crazy to say it was a lot
more fun when you
um online because you could just make
your own custom index yeah yeah and you
can make it updated because the base
deck is so bad the base stick is so
boring I mean also like you know this is
popular in like 2012 yeah years ago yeah
yeah this this game is definitely okay
here's here's the thing you can make the
argument that he hasn't aged well as
well right but I have the same emotions
and feelings towards jackbox and it's a
specifically Whiplash which I think is
so some of the uh the trivia ones are
really the trivia ones are good I like
the trivia ones but as soon as quip lash
comes on
is the word association game oh I hate
that one the the feeling like you you
it's basically Cards Against Humanity
yeah yeah yeah but you fill in the
blanks and they bring it back every
single [__] Jack yeah yeah and you
think it would be funny Until you
realize until someone realizes right
here's his his here's what I hate about
it because once you play it once you
figure out what the rules of the game
are right and if there's one thing that
is not funny to me it's when humor just
feels constructed and unnatural right
because that's that's exactly what Cards
Against Humanity and now Whiplash has
always felt to me because even though
you can put anything in quiplash when
that one mate realizes all you need to
do is to put that in joke that the group
know about everyone starts putting that
in and then that's like you all it takes
is just one one of those answers where
everyone's like you refer to that one
time we all did this stupid thing or
that person did that stupid thing once
uh once the also gets put down that
ruins the entire game of whiplash
because every answer is if it doesn't
come up then it's usually like the
[__] stupidest people yeah I like the
presentation ones too they have to do in
uh jackbox you have to present something
yeah I always like those as well the
patently stupid one yeah like a painting
yeah oh yeah that one's good yeah I like
some of the games but yeah quick flash
is kind of is the one I don't really
ever want to play yeah and because like
it's it's just to me that's Cards
Against Humanity 2.0 and I feel there
are so many clones of that game too like
yeah everywhere I remember like I was at
a friend's place and they brought out
this card game uh it's called that's
what she said
and it literally is exactly the same as
Cards Against Humanity except all the
punch lines are your mom jokes and I'm
like I I was blown away I was like
you've somehow managed to make a Cards
Against Humanity that's even less funny
than Cards Against Humanity oh my God it
was hell it was the worst 30 minutes of
my life yeah it's just unfortunate
because I don't want to say that
unfortunately a lot of people just
aren't funny but if there's one way to
make someone unfunny it's by Playing
Cards Against Humanity because there is
a lot of points where you know you know
I'm hanging out with a funny person you
know or you know we're cracking jokes
and then as soon as cars Against
Humanity comes up that just like
completely Nerfs the interaction right
um and I don't know it's
I I always feel like every time he gets
put out I'm that guy who just hates fun
I'm like am I the crazy one here because
I I I've wanted to rant about this for
so long because I've always felt like am
I just the one old Granddad who just
hates
watching people have fun oh no because
you can have fun in other words the
difference between hating someone having
fun
game like hey I'm good on this one you
guys play without me yeah I don't get
pissed I'm not like [__] [__] I
said no why are you having fun without
me I'm like how you how I'm like how
[__] dare you have fun at this card
game this this is what you're having we
could have had any other card game
except this one pathetic it is like the
worst card game I feel like there's like
Solitaire is better yeah yeah I should
all places I think I'd rather play
Solitaire actually because you know the
good thing is at least you can banter in
Solitaire you can't really banter In
Like Cards Against Humanity is on paper
a game you should be able to Banter
about but it's all just it's all just
the equivalent of laughing at PP poo poo
jokes in my mind uh and uh just like a
bit more sophisticated jokes yeah this
is when you make an energy jerk as well
I was like wow that's too far what do
you mean like half these cards are like
[__] there's the other ones where it's
like you know there could be a white
card down you're sifting through all of
yours and then you find one you just
start bursting and laughing that creates
an expectation and then when your car
gets ready no one laughs it makes so
many awkward moments because you can't
be the only one to laugh because then
you'll know that yeah yeah or or that or
that moment where there's like there's
you know I've played games where there's
moments where I'm just like there's I
think I've put down a banger right I
think I've put down the [__] Banger
uh and I think the worst thing they
picked the worst [__] unfunniest
option that makes absolutely zero sense
and I'm like I'm done I'm done
I hate this I hate this game on so many
different levels and just uh yeah I was
in a I was in a situation when someone
like just took it out again and I'm like
maybe maybe it's changed it's been it's
been years it's been years since I
played chaos again it's been years and I
played one game I played like two two
hands and I'm like I'm done I this is
this is my Breaking Point never again
but uh yeah I don't know if it's
specifically Cards Against Humanity or
if I just have an adversion to board
games uh I don't have like so much an
adversion to board games
I just realized that a lot of the times
if there's an option to let's say you
hang out with a group of friends uh if
there's an option just to like Vibe with
each other or an option to do something
active like play a game I would always
add a party like a physical party like
choose just like vibing
um and I don't know if that's just a me
thing or my brain thing because I do
genuinely have fun playing board games
it's the idea of
like ruining the let's say ruining the
not the momentum but like the kind of
like the the board game's kind of in the
way right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the
board game's in the way
um we have fun but it's like a different
kind of fun you know and I don't know I
it's maybe it's just a me thing because
I if there's a specific board game night
I'm always down because like there's a
let's say there's a expectation you're
going to go to this it's like going to a
DND session right there's an expectation
that you're going to go to this and you
can sit down and you can play a board
game and I'm like okay I can mentally
prepare for that but if we're just at a
social Gathering or like a party and
someone brings out a kind of game I'm
like this is just socializing on
training wheels I would rather just
socialize with my mates so you can say
that because you're a social Master guy
well more of a master than like than the
[__] who pulls out Cards Against
Humanity yeah I think it's like an
icebreaker for some people it's right
you like kind of get rid of that tension
in the air uh
yeah I I agree I'm I'm I agree with you
I don't know oh wow oh wow something
something all three of us can finally
agree it's kind of hard to just say that
out loud I saw you fighting internally I
I I agree I agree
surprise yourself with no that wasn't I
mean that was not a hard day you were
like something that came out 10 years
ago not funny now we wouldn't come out
it came out like longer than 10 years
ago because that's what I only ever
played the online version the online
version I think came out in like 20 10
2009 something like that maybe Humanity
uh release date
why is this the top question well what's
the top question it's cards gets you
empty okay for 13 year olds
uh and apparently it's appropriate for
All Humans age eight and up eight and up
eight and a half
I distinctly remember I feel like it's
burning my mind it's like what the
[__] black tar heroin card I don't
know why what it's just this really
unfunny card that I used to always get
when I played it it was like black tar
heroine was one of the prompts and I was
like this is just not funny oh one that
I always remember is SpongeBob's nut
sack and I'm like when was this ever
funny I mean there's just some random
ones that were obviously there for
filler like I remember getting a card
that was just bees like what what can I
do with this there's also bees like with
a question mark as well that always
comes off and I'm like when would I use
this yeah what how can I how can I ever
use this card but oh no one card I
always remember which was actually funny
was getting gang banged by the Blue Man
Group
okay
you're that [__]
I'm laughing at the fact you thought
that's funny when I was 18 I thought
that was funny
no I agree though it's uh I feel like
we've you know maybe it's like kind of
our age or you know the fact that we've
had we've been in so many social
situations that we just kind of want to
chill but like yeah I don't have a
problem with people like kind of
bringing up like board games or card
games and stuff like that during a
hangout but I'm like yeah I just feel
like it's just in the way like it's
unnecessary no I don't I don't mind it
just depends on the game's [__] or Not
Right But even if the game is fun I'm
just like well but like I was having fun
just talking to you guys you know just
having fun like drinking chatting and
chilling you know I thought that's the
kind of vibe we're going for like you
know if if someone pulls out Monopoly
I'm not gonna be like [__] no I am
actually I am going to be like [__] no I
I will not because I get super
competitive
I'm like I'm buying out all the streets
but like you know if yeah if there's a
night where it's just like you're just
hanging out chilling drinking and that's
how it starts and that's how it ends
then I think I prefer that over any
other type of like event yeah